>>> THERE ARE LEGENDS IN
BASKETBALL SO FAMOUS, YOU KNOW
THEM BY ONE NAME.
JORDAN, KOBE, LeBRON, AND THERE
IS A LEGEND WHO IS STATUS IS SO
ICONIC, YOU KNOW HIM BY ONE
LETTER, K, AS IN COACH K.
FOR 42 SEASONS, MIKE KRZYZEWSKI
SERVED AS THE HEAD COACH FOR THE
DUKE BLUE DEVILS.
HE WON FIVE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS BEFORE RETIRING.
I SAT DOWN WITH HIM TO TALK
ABOUT LIFE, COACHING WISDOM, AND
WHAT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
WINNING.
>> IT'S A PRETTY COOL VIEW.
>> YEAH.
>> AND YOU KNOW, ALL THE BANNERS
AND --
>> THAT'S ALL YOUR NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
>> THE FIVE, YEAH, AND FINAL
FOURS AND ACC CHAMPIONSHIPS.
>> YOU'RE OFTEN DESCRIBED BY
PEOPLE IN PROFILES OF YOU AS THE
SON OF A CLEANING WOMAN AND AN
ELEVATOR OPERATOR.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'S HOW YOU
WOULD DESCRIBE YOUR PARENTS.
>> NO, MY PARENTS WERE THE BASIS
OF WHO ME AND MY BROTHER BECAME.
THEY TAUGHT US THE DIGNITY OF
WORK, I EVEN TELL MY TEAMS FOR
YEARS, I WANT YOU TO BE AS TOUGH
AS YOUR MOTHER.
AND JUST THINK ABOUT YOUR
MOTHER, WAS THERE EVER A DAY
THAT SHE DIDN'T SHOW UP?
DID YOU EVER SEE HER SICK?
DID YOU EVER SEE HER TIRED?
I NEVER SAW MY MOM SICK OR
TIRED.
I SAW HER EVERY DAY DOING
EVERYTHING THAT SHE COULD
POSSIBLY DO TO MAKE IT NICE FOR
ME AND MY BROTHER, BILL.
I DIDN'T APPRECIATE IT UNTIL
LATER IN LIFE.
AND MY DAD DIED WHEN I WAS A
SENIOR AT WEST POINT.
HE DIDN'T GO BY THE NAME
KRZYZEWSKI, HE WENT BY THE NAME
"CROSS."
HE WAS ALWAYS AFRAID OF LOSING
HIS JOB BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT
OF ETHNIC DISCRIMINATION AT THAT
TIME.
I DIDN'T REALIZE ALL THE THINGS
THAT MY PARENTS --
>> GAVE UP?
>> GAVE UP.
>> HID?
YOUR PARENTS DIDN'T EVEN WANT
YOU GUYS TO LEARN TO SPEAK
POLISH.
>> POLISH, RIGHT.
>> WHY?
>> AND I DIDN'T FIND OUT THIS
UNTIL LATER, THEY DIDN'T WANT US
TO HAVE AN ACCENT, BECAUSE THEY
WERE AFRAID AGAIN -- THEY'RE IN
THAT TIME, SOMEBODY WITH A VOWEL
AT THE END OF THEIR NAME MAY
HAVE BEEN LOOKED AT DIFFERENTLY.
THEY WERE CONCERNED.
>> THEY WERE TRYING TO PROTECT
YOU.
ME AND MY BROTHER.
>> SO MUCH SO THAT IT WASN'T ON
HIS TOMBSTONE UNTIL --
>> YEAH.
HE WAS IN WORLD WAR II AS
WILLIAM CROSS.
AND SO WHEN HE DIED, AND WE, YOU
KNOW, WERE A LOW-INCOME FAMILY,
THE GOVERNMENT PROVIDES A
TOMBSTONE.
IT SAID "CROSS."
AND WE WEREN'T ABLE TO CHANGE
THAT UNTIL MY MOM PASSED, AND MY
BROTHER AND I MADE SURE IT SAID
KRZYZEWSKI.
I WAS FORTUNATE TO BE INDUCTED
INTO THE BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME
IN 2001 AND ONE OF THE PARTS OF
THE SPEECH AND PROBABLY THE MOST
EMOTIONAL FOR ME WAS, I SAID, I
WISH MY MOM AND DAD WERE HERE
TONIGHT -- I'M GOING TO START
CRYING, TO SEE A KRZYZEWSKI GO
INTO THE HALL OF FLAME.
IT WAS EMOTIONAL THEN, IT'S
EMOTIONAL NOW, BECAUSE I
RECOGNIZED JUST THE LIFE THEY
LED TO MAKE SURE ME AND BILL
WOULD BE TAKEN CARE OF.
AMAZING.
>> HOW MUCH OF WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND HOW YOU'VE LED AND CARRIED
ON THIS NAME SO PROUDLY, IT'S SO
FAMOUS.
I JUST WALKED IN THE KRZYZEWSKI
CENTER.
>> THEY COULDN'T FIND ANOTHER
NAME FOR IT, SO THEY PUT ONE
THAT NO ONE COULD PRONOUNCE.
>> I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
>> YEAH.
YOU CAN TELL SHE'S --
>> PROUD.
>> I'VE BEEN MARRIED 53 YEARS TO
BECKY AND WE KNEW THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE A PARTNERSHIP.
I CALL IT, TWO IS BETTER THAN
ONE IF TWO CAN ACT AS ONE.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO ACT AS ONE.
THAT'S MY FAMILY.
WHENEVER WE PLAYED IN THE
OLYMPICS, WE BROUGHT EVERYBODY.
>> YOU DID?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU DID A LOT OF IT ALL
TOGETHER.
>> I HAVE THREE DAUGHTERS.
>> THEY HOLD YOU DOWN TO EARTH?
>> THEY -- WHATEVER HUMILITY I
DID NOT HAVE, THEY TRY TO
INTERJECT OVER AND OVER, SO WHEN
THERE USED TO BE FAMILY DINNERS
AND PEOPLE WOULD EAT TOGETHER,
AND I WOULD BE SITTING AT A
TABLE WITH MY FOUR GIRLS AND
WE'RE PLAYING CAROLINA OR
MARYLAND OR WHATEVER, AND WE
JUST WON A BIG GAME, AND WE'RE
TALKING AND NOTHING IS SAD.
>> ABOUT YOUR WIN?
>> OR ABOUT THE GAME.
MY WIFE DID A GREAT THING,
POPPY.
WHEN ALL OF MY GIRLS WERE
GROWING UP, WE NEVER HAD
ANYTHING "BASKETBALL" IN THE
HOUSE.
THE PLAYERS WOULD COME OVER, BUT
THERE WEREN'T TROPHIES,
PICTURES --
>> THERE WAS NO SHRINE TO COACH
K. IN YOUR HOUSE?
>> THERE IS NO SHRINE.
AND THERE SHOULDN'T BE, YOU
KNOW.
>> WELL, THERE ARE IN SOME
PEOPLE'S HOUSES.
>> YEAH, NOW BECAUSE IT'S JUST
ME AND NICKY AND OUR DOG, COACH.
>> THERE'S A SHRINE?
>> WELL, I'M IN A BASEMENT
OFFICE -- WELL, THE LOWER
LEVEL -- AND CAN I PUT ANYTHING
I WANT IN THERE.
SO.
WHENEVER I NEED MY EGO BOOST, I
GO DOWN THERE AND START -- MAN,
YOU WERE REALLY GOOD.
NO, I DON'T DO THAT.
>> DO YOU EVER COME STAND HERE
ALONE?
>> I DO.
USUALLY -- NOT A LOT, BUT LATER
AT NIGHT WHEN ALL THE LIGHTS ARE
OUT, THERE MIGHT BE JUST A
LITTLE BIT ON THE NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP BANNERS OR WHENEVER
YOU WALK IN AND YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE IN A FIELD OF DREAMS.
>> THIS IS YOUR FIELD OF DREAMS?
>> YEAH, OR YOU FEEL LIKE, I
BETTER GET OUT OF HERE, BECAUSE
THE BASKETBALL GOD'S ARE GOING
TO PLAY PICKUP HERE IN A LITTLE
BIT.
>> THERE ARE STARS, THERE ARE
STAR PLAYERS, BUT WE'VE SEEN IN
COLLEGE BASKETBALL, IN THE NBA,
THAT WHEN YOU JUST PUT A BUNCH
OF STARS TOGETHER, IT OFTEN
DOESN'T WORK.
>> YOU HEARD THAT EXPRESSION,
LEAVE YOUR EGOS AT THE DOOR.
I HATE THAT EXPRESSION.
>> YOU DO?
>> I HATE IT.
>> BRING YOUR EGO?
>> BRING EVERYTHING YOU'VE GOT.
BRING WHO YOU ARE.
WHY WOULD YOU LEAVE SOMETHING
YOU ARE --
>> TO MAKE ROOM FOR OTHERS?
>> NO, WE SHOULD MAKE THE ROOM
BIGGER.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE NOT CONFINED BY
THE ROOM, WHEN YOU BRING ALL THE
EGOS IN AND PUT THEM UNDER ONE
UMBRELLA, THAT'S WHAT WE DID FOR
YOU, AND IT SAID "USA" ON IT,
AND THEN YOU DEVELOP COMMON
GROUND.
YOU WANT A QUICK STORY?
>> YEAH.
I WANT ALL THE STORIES.
>> JASON KIT, FIRST PRACTICE,
OUR CAPTAIN, HALL OF FAMER,
LEADING A FAST BREAK DRILL,
DWYANE WADE IS IN ONE LANE,
LeBRON'S IN ANOTHER, AND THE
BALL'S GOING EVERYWHERE.
SO I BRING THEM TOGETHER, AND I
KNOW WE CAN'T PLAY LIKE THIS,
BEFORE I SAY ANYTHING, JAY KITT
SAYS, COACH, I'LL TONE IT IMMED
DWAYNE SAID, NO, NO, NO, WE'VE
NEVER PLAYED WITH A TALENT LIKE
YOU.
WE'LL ADAPT TO YOU.
>> REALLY?
>> YES.
IT WAS ONE OF THE GREAT MOMENTS
IN MY COACHING CAREER WHERE I
SAW TALENT SAY, COME ON, TALENT,
GIVE ME MORE.
IT WAS LIKE THE PIANO PLAYER
TELLING THE SAX PLAYER, COME ON,
GO, I CAN PLAY THE PIANO BETTER,
SINGER.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IF YOU CAN GET
EVERYONE PLAYING WITH ALL THEIR
TALENT, WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT
TALENT TO MAXIMIZE?
>> YES.
>> AND IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE
TO GIVE UP TALENT TO MAXIMIZE.
AND IF ALL THAT WORKS TOGETHER,
WOW.
>> HOW MANY PRESIDENTS HAVE YOU
MET?
ALL OF THEM IN YOUR LIFETIME
>> ALL OF THEM.
EVEN WHEN WE W, IN 41
PRESIDENT BUSH BECAME A CLOSE
FRIEND.
>> THIS IS YOU AND KOBE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS U.S., THANKS
FOR ALL THE GOLDEN MOMENTS.
THIS IS A GREAT BOOK FOR ME
BECAUSE EACH PLAYER GAVE THEIR
QUOTE.
>> SO CAN WE READ WHAT LeBRON
SAID ABOUT YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> HE ALLOWS US TO PLAY THE GAME
OF BASKETBALL AND JUST GO OUT
THERE AND HAVE FUN, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME HE WANTS US TO BE
PERFECT.
WE SHOULD EXPECT PERFECTION AND
THAT IS WHAT HE IS ABOUT.
WE LIKE THAT.
WE LIKE THAT KIND OF CHALLENGE.
>> YEAH.
>> READ THE LAST LINE KOBE SAID
ABOUT YOU.
>> COACH K. IS ONE OF THE BEST
COACHES OF ALL TIME, PERIOD, NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT YOU IS HOW HARD
YOU ARE ON YOURSELF.
AND THAT THERE HAVE BEEN MOMENTS
WHEN YOU WILL ACTUALLY -- YO
LOOKED IN THE MIRROR OVER YOUR
CAREER AND CURSED YOURSELF OUT.
>> WE ARE ALL BETTER IF WE ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU KNOW, HOW YOU HOLD PLAYERS
ACCOUNTABLE ALONG THE YEARS
CHANGE BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN TOUGH ON THEM,
VERY.
>> WELL, YOU HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
SOMETIMES THERE'S NOBODY THAT
HOLDS THE LEADER ACCOUNTABLE,
IT'S ON YOU, I DID IT, YOU KNOW,
I NEED TO CHANGE.